what you're about to see is a discussion
that i had with father siloan justiniano
father silawon is a hieromonk he is also
a priest in the orthodox church but
mostly
to us he is really an artist in my
estimation uh father siluwan is one of
the most important artist
visual artists in north america today
in the sense that his understanding of
traditional iconography his attention to
detail his mastery of color his capacity
to
bring in strains from different uh
traditional arts but also from
contemporary art into a sacred art which
is powerful and is present while also
being very traditional and i think that
he offers us a
vision of what um north american
orthodox
sacred art could look like but not only
that i believe that he can also point us
to a direction in which you know
sacred art can be a model even for
secular art gallery art but also popular
art as well and so in our discussion we
talk about visual art we talk about the
traditional doctrine of art
as was formulated by uh an art an art
historian ananda kumar sami at the at
the beginning of the century and so we
go through
much of contemporary art modern art and
also how it connects to iconography and
so it's a very rich and powerful
discussion and i'm very happy to be
sharing it with you today
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
um so what i want to do is i i i
definitely want to talk about art i want
to kind of revisit the conversation we
had a few years ago that i didn't that i
didn't record well uh this one should be
good because i know what i'm doing now
uh and so that's what i mostly want to
do and i want people i want you to talk
about your art and your approach
um you know i had aiden hart on and i
had um other other people
and i'm trying to kind of create
communication channels between
secular art world and the sacred sacred
art and it's working like i i'm getting
it's crazy like the people that are
reaching out to me is it's nuts like in
the secular art world and the amount of
catechumen that are coming in from the
art world it's it's exciting because
that's very important man because
that
what you just described like the bridge
or like the conversation beginning
that's all that's like
we've been we
it's been a need that's that's that has
not been addressed at all at least in
the anglophone world as i have come to
to to understand what has been happening
in like you know late 20th century
you know
uh 21st century like orthodoxy
unfortunately
has a treasure
of things to offer but it tends to
suffer
from
isolation or a a
insularity
that that is is counterproductive and
one of my my
concerns
for many years has been how do you
engage in that conversation with nuance
but without compromise and it's a hard
one it's a hard one and sometimes i
think i got it grasped
and and then it slips out of you know
out of control i don't i don't it's hard
to
to to to to engage it but one of the key
factors that i found that like helps to
to deal with the problem is
having a cognizance of the historical
uh
paradigm
of
fine art
as as we have come down to understand it
since the 18th century
if we if we come to an understanding
that
something shifted in terms of
what was what we tend to
in our community call the traditional
doctrine of
art from that to
to the fine art paradigm
then you have a better sort of like
feel to to to you know to place things
into
and to to come up with better answers i
think because if you don't have that
then you you're more muddled
it's more confusing
so maybe maybe we can start with that
maybe you can
lay that out for us i mentioned it a few
times on the channel but i would really
love to hear your take on what is what
happened what is the change between the
the kind of traditional vision of the
arts and the fine art paradigm
one one thing that i think
is important to keep in mind is that we
could
um
become a bit too
um
abstract in in sort of like isolating
this idea of the traditional doctrine
and in separating it
from like
historical developments that occurred
uh and i'm mainly primarily thinking of
like
you know the industrial revolution the
development of the of the the middle
class
uh the development of capitalism uh you
know all these technological
advancements and like the the the
paradigm shifts in terms of like uh
government
uh political all these things played a
factor in in
in creating the
uh environment
in which
the change occurred so the traditional
doctrine of our as you've mentioned
multiple times in your lectures and like
uh
in in
your your uh
channel
basically
you're dealing with
a functional art
uh you're dealing with
function that is not or symbolism that
is not separated from function
and it is
aspects of or understand understanding
of beauty that is not separated from
function either
so
it is
an art that is meant to address both
physical and and spiritual needs
and
the
art
um
that we're talking about
in a way
did not
make a stark distinction between sacred
and secular spheres as much as we tend
to okay so you could have
um
a a
courtly art that
used what we consider to be a sacred
theme or vice versa and you and
stylistically there were no distinctions
between how you would depict things in
the church and how you would depict them
in the court or in in the folk context
in the village they they were more
closely linked you you could have levels
of refinement
of that art but but ultimately it was an
art that was geared towards an um
way that i would put it
some people might not like the idea
because it comes from a a 19th century
art critic
uh it's an ideaistic art
it's it's an id the idea
comes first so to speak and then you you
embody that idea
uh with
representational forms
but the representation is not confined
to
an empirical assessment of nature it's
not based on an empiricist understanding
of
nemesis or imitation of nature so so
kumaraswamy would at times use a phrase
i think that derives from aristotle art
imitates nature in her
uh
method of operation or something like
that
so so in other words
our in this case is
mother nature
or actually
is is is god creating okay so so so
the the uh
it touches on the idea the christian
idea that uh the lord has specific like
divine wills or a pattern paradigm
uh
and then he actualizes this paradigm in
his creation when he he names it he
calls it to being and they are created
based on this idea yeah and so the art
would be something like there's a
purpose for the yes exactly and then
that purpose is now embodied in body yes
is aimed at that purpose exactly is
embodied meaning okay
um and so so that's that's a very
important thing and that's always
plugged into
a metaphysic because
because
prior to philosophy as we understand it
philosophical questions metaphysical
questions
were dealt with in a traditional society
in terms of symbolism
and so so the art that was created
used a symbolic language in order to
convey
uh the
cosmology
or
um doctrinal
meanings
that they held to be
valuable for the health of the community
or for the
overall ordering of the community
um
and so
um
that has to also be kept in mind so so
so there was no separation between
uh religion and art and so
you know so and there was no such thing
as
the uh
are as
expressive of individualist
ideas it was expressive of metaphysical
doctrines or the meanings that the
community held to be
of uh pivotal importance for its
well-being and so
that's one
that's one abbreviated you know
uh understanding of of of uh
look a more traditional vision more
traditional yes and and also bear in
mind that this was also the artist
worked within a continuity of
traditional forms
and and iconology
so all traditional forms are
iconological
uh insofar as
the meanings are contained in specific
uh compositional formulations
that convey these specific meanings
and of course um
you could never escape yourself insofar
as like you will always handle these
forms in what in a way that is unique to
yourself so that you could trace
stylistic differences within
a traditional culture but the stylistic
differences are the accidents not the
essence of the art as kumaswami would
put it so
so this is you know so anonymity tended
to be the norm where the
artist didn't sign the you know the the
the art
and uh and it wasn't really looked at
for the sake of deriving some
biographical understanding who the
artist was yeah and so so um
so these are all important distinctions
uh and the contrast uh they say they
help to create the contrast between uh a
post
between traditional and post
18th century paradigm uh and after the
uh 18 you know during the 18th century
we have to keep in mind we have the
development of aesthetics as its own
discipline as a discipline within the
realm of philosophy
and of course his aesthetics is like a
is pertaining to things of sense but it
was like a philosophical inquiry as to
what
that could be in terms of a form of
cognition and so it was analyzed
philosophically and of course it also
had to deal with the judgment of taste
and so
how
can we explain
our cognition of
what we consider to be beautiful and or
along those
forms of inquiry you have what is
considered sublime okay so you have like
edwin burks the inquiry into the ideas
of the of the beautiful and the sublime
and then you have uh the critique of
judgment by uh
by kant and then you have uh i forgot
the the initiator of actually the term
aesthetics the german baumgarten i think
it was uh that started uh you could you
correct me if i'm wrong but i forgot i'm
not sure i don't know that actual last
name but i think he was one of the first
ones it makes sense that it's a german
that's for sure right right right it was
like germans were like the in the
forefront of our history too so that's
right so then you have you have that
development plus also the development of
the museum
which is very important and one of the
things that people forget is that the
museum was partly
developed uh
as a consequence of the french
revolution uh you know the there were
museums before then if i'm not mistaken
in austria if i'm
mistaken because there were the
development actually from the cabinet of
curiosities right exactly yeah the
cabinet makes total sense yeah that's
what museums are cabinets and
curiosities so so you would have like
all this like whatever a king or prince
considered to be worthy of his
curious attention you know chemical
things like you know uh
like archaeological things like uh
relics uh precious objects jewelry you
know whatever i mean they would have
this as a chamber where they could go
and pass their time study
uh manuscripts they would have there and
then it was it was pretty pretty
all-inclusive it wasn't as like you know
as demarcated as we have it in museums
now and it was a place where you could
invite people that you respected to go
and talk about these items but then that
developed into a public form
later on and it takes off really in like
the uh french revolution aft because
they basically faced the dilemma
the aestheticians
and people who
value these works independent of their
political
or religious
implication
they were like well we don't want to
because they were destroying all this
stuff right it's like is french
revolution iconoclasm right so we're
destroying this as like representative
of the old
regime world right exactly and so so
then they decided
oh well i forgot who it was like uh
called up the attention all right we
can't be destroying everything so what
are we gonna do so basically they
decided to actually
move these items to a museum in a
gallery space that became independent
or was
a was was meant to be independent of any
ideological political implication
and so the the
the excuse was we are putting these here
because of their aesthetic value not
because of its religious or
political value so it was an attempt to
inaccurate the the artwork from
its uh religious and political content
and to and to have it be that's sort of
like a a a
an example of
a a
social way in which the the theory of
the autonomous artwork begins to take
hold right yeah and so then what you
have in the fine art context is the idea
of the autonomous work of art
uh you have the idea of
the artist as independent
uh from any
patrons like demands it takes more and
more hold of that
you know that becomes more and more
stronger as as we go along and move on
from the 18th century on
um you have the
uh
beauty as a
form of
taste as
different from beauty as a theophany of
the divine
you could perhaps find in aspects of
romanticism traces of that because i
think one of the things that you have to
keep in mind sorry to like you know
digress is that a lot of these things
are
are
distortions of christian doctrine that's
right yeah exactly
and so so you do have aspects in which
perhaps a romantic painter considered
beauty and the sublime the sublime
by the way is the
experience of grandeur in nature where
you feel your limitation and you
experience all or your utter like
weakness in in in the
face by the forces of nature
standing at the top of a cliff exactly
feeling that yeah exactly so it's
different from beauty and so far as
beauty is something that is more
that you could handle that like or is
more is closer to you and so burke would
say like
uh like the the the sub curve soft
curvature or like soft skin and things
like that that we all usually associate
with the sensuous and it's not
threatening to us it's actually
comforting for us
as compared to to the sublime which is
like actually a storm
uh the the cliffs you know and the alps
or you know or the the ominous feeling
of like you know a forest you know where
you're like small and you're like
surrounded by this like you know uh
indeterminacy or like you're you're you
don't know what's gonna happen when you
enter it you know and so it it it's
related to horror or terror and things
like that so it's like the it's related
to the idea of the divine as the all
terrifying you know the the numinous
notions of like uh otto what's his name
that guy that wrote the uh ideas of like
the uh of the numinous anyway so so you
have these and so these are these are
like vestiges of christian ideas you
could say that are still playing out in
like a post-enlightenment context but
they are then channeled in a different
direction and they mainly become
channeled through
an individualistic form of expression
now yeah and that that takes off on on
the on the on the romantic period but we
have to call him in mind also that the
romantic period is a rebuttal of
rationalism
of the enlightenment yeah and so
what they do is okay we cannot go to
religion
in its usual like
traditional forms
so we're going to actually the
subjective becomes a realm through which
and the imagination becomes the
venue through which we actually
very privately encounter the divine
and so we
are going to rebuttal the limitations of
rationalism is mechanistic and kind of
like you know
uh
cold uh
approach to reality uh
it's limiting approach to reality in a
way that
it emphasizes they thought like
emotion as related to the spiritual and
mainly being an alternative to the
religious
communal context
as you would have it in traditional
religion and so
so then that became the seedbeds of what
would eventually become
the ideas that
gave uh
ground
or the foundation for
the 19th century
subjectivist tendencies that lead up to
abstraction
and so so
uh what am i missing i think there's so
so you you do have you do have what i
would say is this
getting back to the whole thing about
bridging the the the uh
the conversation between orthodox
the orthodox context and the
the art world
i think
some of the narratives
that we've used in the past
have been too simplistic
in terms of creating too stark of a
dichotomy between
um
a christian worldview and
a
what we think of as a secular war view
what i mean by that is this
if because what could happen is
we create this like
box okay these are the ideas that gave
rise to these
forms
so then it becomes difficult to see
exceptions to the rule or to like
actually see how even within
the post 18th century context you still
have vestiges of religion vestiges of
the spiritual you know what i'm saying
so so what we need to do in my opinion
is to find a theological way
of
teasing this out
to discern
these
tendencies
um
that
you cannot
you cannot do away with because we're
all human beings
and although the the the main current
might be an anti-religion or current or
it might be a current that like actually
contradicts a lot of the uh
aspects of orthodoxy
nevertheless human beings are human
beings and and they will
even inadvertently aspire towards the
divine or aspire towards
uh a humanism that is christian within
that context and i think you've done
some of that
in your critique of some social social
uh how they call it uh
uh popular arts yeah you know what i'm
saying like and you're using you're
doing exactly that with the way you're
like revalorizing the the the uh um
the uh
uh what is it uh graphic novel yeah okay
so so so i think that's that's because
for example i don't know if you're
familiar i'm sure you are
uh
the only thing that i heard about uh uh
uh
you know art
treating it philosophically or
as a critique
from a christian perspective was francis
schaefer how shall we then live for
example yeah as protestant theologian
you know very famous for his like
critique of like western civilization
and like but the problem is that it
became too simplistic
and and the artwork then either was
it fell under like
you know he would deprecate it as either
nihilistic or existential or like
whatever you know or anti-christian
values and so so the artwork was not
approached as a thing you experience in
a participatory way or an opportunity
for communing
with embodied meaning even with it
outside of the realm of like a
traditional context or christian
christian
ecclesial life
but but rather it was considered to be
purely a channel
for a world view and if you didn't like
the world view then you dismissed the
artwork yeah
yeah yeah i mean that's why
the tr
that's why the art downstream from
shaffer is just propaganda it's just
it's just
it's just really very shallow
uh that all those christian movies that
you see you know are are are very weak
and they're weak in their structure
they're weak in their narrative they're
weak in their in their visuals and they
they're just basically a vehicle for a
message basically
yeah so getting back to what i was
saying about the whole issue of the
beautiful like the
like you've pointed this out in some of
your lectures about
how
uh
you have now like the the complete
separation between function and beauty
but you know in the in the finite in the
fine art paradigm um
so
um
so the fine art paradigm
is usually you know uh
you know you have sculpture painting
uh
uh
uh poetry
architecture
dance for example music you know so
these are all different categories or
different realms or practices
disciplines within the
larger paradigm of the fine art practice
but the thing is that
after the 60s as you know
but but beginning like in the
very big you know the 20 the 19th
century already in the yeah already in
there yeah like well you know with with
dusha for example which you know i hold
dear although he is infamous you know
for because of a specific reason and
these uh i explained
he basically critiqued the fine art
paradigm
so this is
you can look him up if you don't know
who he is he's very important yeah where
we are today right so so he basically
then
like
created like began
he was like the initiator of a
questioning of the finite paradigm
so so contemporary are as we know since
the 60s
okay with pop r you know neo data
conceptualism all these things even
aspects of like minimalism you know all
these like actually all these movements
tend to be anti-aesthetic
yeah they're not concerned with notions
of beauty anymore okay and so so we have
to keep in mind that that that as well
so so he is an initiator of that that
tendency because he says okay our till
now has been retinol because he's
basically critiquing the 19th century
uh
tendency
of like for example the impressionism
post-impressionists you look at nature
and then you have you have a sensation
or or you you you filter it through your
temperament and then what you produce
although independent from nature is an
autonomous object nevertheless
it's based on your sensations right and
so so he says well but even that has an
aspect of idea because
they are actually
experiencing a sensation and then
ideastically and this is
i'll get back to that but this is a
connection between modern and
traditional art yeah they are
idealistically then
translating this sensation so he said
forget forget about the forget about the
sensation he says
you know because art is its own thing it
is a conceptual framework
and we're forgetting that and we're so
getting trapped
wrapped up in our sensations and beauty
and the whole institution of fine art
that is not allowing us to actually
address what art is or could be the
ontology of our so to speak and so he
begins to
explore that okay and then that opens up
a whole kind of worms
you know that leading to like you know
the rabbit holes that we you know of
course would not you know be uh
inevitable you know we would be we would
not agree with but yeah well i mean just
the the situation of art now you could
say like the situation the post-modern
uh our the art market it's the most
fascinating thing about dusha is how he
was totally recuperated by the system
and actually
and actually his ideas it's like now
there's a massive you know uh guggenheim
bilbao that is like this multi-million
dollar complex to house all the children
of marseilles you know and how expensive
all these art pieces are yeah and so the
thing is that that he then also
inadvertently opened up the avenue for
the expanding of
the aesthetic
because now people do similar things
and they're looked at for their
aesthetic value or even most people go
to the museum and look at his fountain
for aesthetic values you know what i'm
saying and so it's like so so you know
so things are like all over the place
you know it becomes more and more like
uh
uh like an amoeba of like you know
phenomena
no no and and it's like it's because
what you have is like you don't have
a
let's call it an imaginal like
the imaginal
horizon so to speak
like in a traditional context the
imaginal horizon was very specific based
on metaphysical assumptions
and and it it ordered based on this
metaphysical assumptions first of all by
default
it was man's relationship to the
transcendent the divine the gods or
whatever
and then based on that then how do we
shape
our
our
lives
yeah based on the heavenly pattern as
above so below
and so
but the stories in the art would also be
grounded from below at through function
yes that is the fact that you have
objects that have to have a function in
the world would would connect heaven and
earth basically whereas with
contemporary art because you've unmoored
the the ground even and now you're also
on more at the top you just have this
amoeba it's a great way to get it just
have this free-floating chaos exactly
that is just a kind of expression of
variation itself you could say yeah so
what you have now it's like a a um
or you know another way of putting it
it's like you know how like you have
foam
and foam is composed of this little tiny
like uh bubbles or like you know you
know of of
they're like little cells composing this
so you can imagine the art world right
now as foam
composed of all these little like
bubbles which are like you know the the
the
like they're independent semiotic like
fields of meaning like so so each artist
has to invent his own
his own symbolism or his semiotic like
you know uh uh interpretation of of
reality or how he engages with the the
social cultural sphere or if he's
addressing aspect of like ontology how
he like interprets uh our humanity or
whatever and so so then when you
encounter it you're at a loss because
you don't you don't you're not part of
the same imaginal horizon and so so what
is hard for most people
is that by default if you're going to
engage with that you have to become
versed in history you have to be become
versed in art theory you have to be
conversed in the specific work of the
artist and how he actually plays into
this whole foam of
cross-fertilized meanings and that's a
very hard thing to do it's like it's
ultimately is an interpretive uh
critical act that is very difficult to
engage with but it's
it's sort of like its own
it's like uh
it's in it's it's it's its own um
uh
for example i like to i like to compare
these i have to use this contrast
i think
from a christian perspective an orthodox
perspective there is a tendency we think
that it's
easier for a person to go into an
orthodox church and to understand what's
going on than to go to a museum and
understand what's going on okay
there is a sense in which this is true
and it's not true
yeah
because i think i think it i think it's
i think it's true in the sense that
the let's say the um
the it's ramping up is as difficult that
is you have to you have to kind of gain
a world view but once you have it then
everything lays it falls into
my thing is the initial encounter is an
initial encounter is difficult because
if you are not versed in the iconology
you have to learn that language
and you will have intuitions that are
perhaps more immediate because
you know they they are using
we are using
forms that are
universally relatable so far i mean
human faces exact figures like these
things are all right right deeply
connected to our experience yes yes and
so in that sense it is more accessible
uh but there is a similarity
not one to one similarity of like the
challenge of actually
immersing yourself
in the theology in the cosmology in the
symbolic structures and patterns for you
to be able to interpret what it is that
you're seeing in a more in-depth way
yeah and so so um
so yeah so that's uh
and there's a difference too like
there's a difference because because
there is this hierarchy
uh in the language and there's a
communal aspect to it and there's a
notion of kind of bringing you up
towards higher worlds
the the
let's say the effort you put into
learning the language will lead you up
towards virtue will lead you up towards
exactly and that's much because in the
contemporary art world you just
nihilistically move from bubble to
bubble and and it's like this infinite
and you're you you have to kind of get
used to idiosyncrasy as an experience
it's like sometimes you think that
people that go into museums
get some kind of coherent
uh experience but they don't they just
actually are used to
idiosyncratic uh let's say collage and
they actually see that as a reflection
of the real which is a deeply nihilistic
nihilistic act in itself that's uh
that's uh actually relates to to
to what i was doing which
parallels the way what you were doing
when you were in uh in our school so i
want to i want maybe that's a good time
to back up a little bit yeah because we
kind of jumped right into the
conversation which is great but maybe
you can tell people a little bit about
your own uh story uh that is how you
kind of moved
into the contemporary art world and then
moving out of the contemporary art world
into iconography and ultimately trying
to find ways to
to maybe enrich the language as much as
as is reasonable or yeah
uh the um
how how should i frame this
um
i i grew up as a protestant uh
my my parents were pentecostal
and and so throughout my youth i pretty
much
um
uh
struggled with that
because i didn't really
you know i didn't really want to be part
of it but eventually to the grace of god
i i had to confront what i really
believed and that was during my
undergrad during i went for one year at
a
the maryland institute college of art in
baltimore and there that was a reality
check because then it really became like
a confrontation between world views yeah
me talking to people and like you know
like for example i took for granted the
existence of the soul and i would go to
a party and talk to people that like
were totally denying the existence of
the soul i'm like
you must be crazy and then i stepped
back and i said all right i'm trying to
argue for something that i'm like
i'm like rejecting my parents
what does that what does that mean about
you know what do i really believe you
know what i'm saying and so that
precipitated the whole process of like
you know
at that time i like uh
i encountered
uh for the first time like that little
treatise by vasily kandinsky considering
the spiritual in art
that was like a
big
eye-opener because i didn't really know
that there was
a slice of the modern art world that
dealt with
spiritual matters right you know they
questioned what that means but you know
but it leads an effort to like yes like
yes a lot of these these artists were
actually
were actually spiritualists were
involved in ethiopia and all these kind
of fringe spiritual things but it but it
wasn't just pure materialism exactly
exactly so so then you know
moving forward i i
um decided to commit my my life towards
following christ in the in his gospel
and
but that was before i i came
to to orthodoxy my dad bumped into an
antioquine priest in his high school
with the high school where he was
working and then that precipitated
conversation my dad told me about it i
went to visit the antiochus church and
that was my first instance of like
actually looking at a liturgy and like
and the incense and the icons and i
couldn't really i was all i know is that
i was like i was digging it but i don't
know i couldn't really put my finger on
it intellectually it took years for me
to like actually piece it together
but i was like
i would go to the
to the bible studies wednesday nights
in the protestant church where we
attended and i was like i want to go to
liturgy this sunday man i mean i want
something more like you know
experiential you know anyways so
uh eventually when i went to grad school
then i became orthodox i was received
into the church
and so
during undergrad i was doing you know
abstract expressionist kind of work and
then
towards the end of my undergrad i i
shifted focus and i started to do more
like geometric
uh
based work
uh
from
collage
compositions that i would uh
uh
put together
so so
which relates to what you were saying
about the fragmentation thing right so i
would take clips from magazines and you
know
and and evocative kind of like
suggestive kind of like imagery and then
combine it in a in a grid like
structure um
and then i would execute it in oils then
that's
in the mid 80s right
this was in the no man at this 90s sorry
midnight
yeah this was in 1990 uh
four
okay 96 i went grad school
you'll be a combination of uh death of
the author
a critique of greenbergian
uh modernism
and um
um
the ideas of the simulacra body
yeah and um
and the pivotal
influence for everyone at the time was
uh gerhard richter yeah
i was looking at like
uh so i was i was basically doing
what you could
call
conceptual abstraction
and it was
it was uh related to pop too because
given that it was a critic of the author
it was
um
uh predicated on
appropriation
so so i was taking
taking images from
from uh
popular culture
fragments of photography i would even
photograph
uh
a tv screen of garble channels yeah and
uh and then i would i would put these
images together to resemble
computer screens
but
um it had a dimension of illusionism
because it was photorealistically
executed
and it had a connection to geometric
abstraction
so so it was
both geometric organic illusionistic
it was it was sort of like
imperial painting imperial abstraction
which was a the critique of greenberg
because greenberg had this idea that for
painting to become is his true
self like or or to
um
it was a modernism was sort of like a
gradual progression towards the
culmination of the true identity of
painting and part of it involved like
the rejection of illusionism the
inherent properties of painting as
flatness
and so um which ended in absolute
nonsense
like rolls of canvas with like right
like splashes of color exactly right
right so so i was i i i actually
uh i was into color and and and so i was
i was uh playing with all these ideas
and but the thing is that
um
and by the way a uh digression which i
think i have to mention my my my
professors at
hunter college where i was going for
graduate school where there were um
uh
a very interesting school they
they were colorists they they they're if
you look it up you know they're like
they're
they're considered the hunter color
school right so
um
they but but
their work
had it influenced my work
but i was also rebelling against it yeah
because there was
i used this very thin stripe kind of
like uh
uh
surface for
for my images were it created an optical
effect
the images hovered so to speak
and so because i would i would
put contrasting colors hues like
green red like orange you know and blue
and and so
given that it they were put together in
in very close proximity stripe like
forms
uh you know structure
it would create a hovering effect and a
vibration but this was partly related to
what uh sanford warmfeld was doing he
was the chair of the art department at
hunter
and he he he
he had a course called the color seminar
that i took that was very important and
and i derived a lot of
you know good influence from that
but i i thought that their approach was
too scientistic and it was still part of
like the continuation of what was
happening in the late 19th century with
surat and like you know the the color
theory that was happening at the time
they you could you could say that they
are a current form of that or they can
they they're closely related to that
history
and
my my advisor my thesis advisor was
robert swain and he also did work based
on color very much about finding a
a system a color system based on the
color wheel that and so he has
you know developed a color system that
he very systematically arranges he's got
like 400 and
maybe like i don't know if it's 400 4
000 i mean thousands of colors that he
has arranged and he has to
systematically numbered in his studio
and he moves these around in like
to create compositions and like
so to me it was like you guys are too
crazy to to
too scientistic anyways but
yeah so there was the environment
and so
but at the same time i was like really
appreciative as as to to me
they call that painting based on
warfare's like uh theory they called it
presentational painting
instead of representation it was
presentation right
a presentation of a color phenomenon
yeah and to me that was very evocative
very
and and has a lot of potential because
in my view
it's presenting a phenomenon that is
offered to us by god
but the this painters are like actually
focusing on it
and bringing it to you so you can
experience it and to me that dimension
getting back to what we were saying
about how we could interpret something
as having a theological implication
although people who did it might not
even have that in mind to me if you look
at that work along those lines you could
actually interpret it in a very fruitful
way in any case so i was
surrounded by all this stuff and i was
doing sort of like a partly a critique
of that and partly going along with the
spirit of the times in terms of
post-modern painting conceptual painting
and my thesis was
a look into the mechanics of visual
pleasure so
given that i was by default always
interested in the spiritual dimensions
or dynamic in modern art
i was continuing to do that so my view
was
part of the fine art paradigm is you're
redeeming things by decontextualizing
them you bring them into the realm of
art and by default is a higher a higher
context okay in this cultural sphere
okay
so you experience it as somehow insofar
as it is no longer part of the real
world it is higher right so so so in my
mind at the time i was like taking all
these advertisements
decontextualizing them putting them in a
context of geometric abstraction which
was
by default in his history related to
aspirations towards the transcendent
and
creating what i called a pseudo
spirituality within the realm of a
contemporary painting right and i was
uh using fragments of
visual fragments of culture that in my
view
were
a material a spirit um
a
materialistic spiritualism if that makes
any sense yeah because when you look at
advertisement they use for example
a they use color
light
notions of purity
and they try to exalt the
object they're selling
towards almost making it into a saint
right make it putting it in the realm of
the transcendent so i was basically
using that kind of reference material
bringing it into painting and
questioning aspects of
the transcendent value of painting and
how ultimately if it is a commodity
object it is planned into the whole
pseudo materialistic spirituality of the
market
that was in my mind part of what was
going on but
that was at the same time of me becoming
orthodox finding out about monasticism
and so there was a transition that was
taking place
and i was
getting closer to the probability of
entering into the monastic life and i
was like playing with the idea and i
didn't know
meanwhile i
i finished up graduate school i was i'm
just one question like at any point did
you experience a kind of schizophrenia
in the in the let's say in the
contemporary art world
and this movement towards orthodoxy i
say that because i was experiencing that
in during my degree in art which is at
some point i was doing these things here
and i was doing these things here and i
was and and it was just ripping me apart
like i don't know if you had that
experience yeah so yes that was
definitely part of it i mean because it
was you know
not to be you know uh
not too down
or
the the the protestant protestant
brethren out there but but i i was like
and at a time i was like thinking to
myself you know our world is like
protestantism it's like you have
different different denominations
of like
of of of of
doctrines
and and i'm i'm
part and me participating in this
it's like i'm like in in another i'm
trying to like come up with like ideas
that like for what purpose i was asking
myself i mean i i have i have the
orthodox faith
and so
that already
is is is all-encompassing it's like
everything is is is
is put in order
there is a
structure
of meaning that like
i don't need to be re
in reinventing the wheel but meanwhile
i'm doing this artwork that it
predicates always reinventing the wheel
because you have to always
come up with an idea that moves
the ball ahead somehow or whatever that
means whatever that means right
so so then it's like
and then i was in a dilemma it's like
do i want to just create beautiful
objects for people to be gratified
and but what does that really mean and
even if i come up with good ideas are
they even that good or
helpful in
the ultimate goal of our existence here
in this world
and so then when i when i looked at
things in terms of like priorities i was
like well
there's a priority i have to say that a
liturgical art is
by default higher than than
the paradigm that i'm experiencing it
yeah i was thinking in
in graduate school because
it it
it
leads man towards it's he's his intended
ultimate goal
the ultimate good
and and it's it's
it's
it's more um
all embracing because this is functional
it's symbolic it's it's got aspects of
beauty but it's not solely predicated on
beauty and it's is is is leading man
towards god so what else should i i mean
why why would i do anything else right
but at that time but
what you're saying is so interesting
because there and i think this is going
to lead us towards the way in which we
can bring some of this back in yeah what
it feels like is that
there's an aspect of a lot of the
contemporary art world and a lot of
modernism which is almost like a hyper
focusing as you said let's say hyper
focusing on color like a hyper focusing
on the sublime hyper focusing on these
different aspects of experience
and whereas the liturgical
experience has it all there right and so
it's like if you think there's no
sublime in communion you're not paying
attention my friend it's like it's there
and and if you think that you know if
you think there is in beauty all these
things are there and so but there's a
possibility interesting possibility to
look at these hyper specializations in
almost as like these in their heresies
but see how they can they teach us
something about
that aspect also right it's like the the
work on color that was done in the
modern the modern era it's something
that the ancients didn't have access to
which is yes amazing work this is
important what you're saying is very
important that we have to i think as
orthodox christians
learn
how to engage with
the contemporary art world
in an honest way
but in a more
nuanced way i think
taking into consideration exactly what
you're talking about for example i was
looking at donald j i was looking at a
doc another documentary
an interview of the daughter of donald
judd who was interviewed uh for
the occasion of some big exhibition
of his work he's a
like one of the greatest minimalists
right so or he probably wouldn't have
liked that term but in any case
uh
and
as they're talking to her they have this
footage of like some of his sculptures
and it dawned on me the guy was total
empiricist
he was like
totally
non-religious
atheist
and i was looking at his work
and i was beginning to notice
myself tracing his ordering structure
and and and experiencing myself
uh
in a way contemplating
the
ordering system that he brought into
this and how sometimes
you almost grasp it but then it slips
out of your your your
your grasp
and i'm like
this has
you could analyze that in a way that
actually you could do a critique a a
an interpretation
that that is exactly what you're saying
looking at this hyper
um
approach to
cognition or
or
our mind's capacity to order reality
in a way where it brings out of the
viewer a contemplative experience
of an object
that in a way serves as a
parallel
to prayer
it is a gathering experience because you
become aware of like you know how like
uh you have seen uh denise's your epigod
he's got the linear prayer and then the
circular prayer and then the spiral
prayer right right so i think some works
can be seen and partly
even even inadvertently even by people
who don't even believe in god they
create a situation in which you become
aware of your capacity to have a higher
level of cognition yeah and and to me
that is like
the same thing with the color painters
that i mentioned that i'm indebted to
from hunter college so uh and so so i
think that's an important thing to keep
in mind because if we just always
approach it as
this work is illustrative of this false
idea or illustrative of this decadent
period in history or illustrative of a
worldview that is destructed to man it's
like
the reality is as orthodox christians we
have been given the capacity to see
christ in everything
and we have to not forget that the logos
is always playing in fields and places
that we don't expect he's playing
and so
let's just look for him and have more of
a of of an openness to to not
ignore
when things are clearly spiritually
destructive but also realize that not
things are not always so
so starkly you know black and white you
know yeah and the way the christians
what they did to roman art
they did exactly what we're talking
about which is that there's a there's
let's say in roman in roman in in
hellenistic and roman art there's a kind
of
there's a kind of glorious human that is
that is put on
in front of us and that that tendency
tends to become excessive in the
sensuality in the kind of sexual aspect
of it and uh and or even in the extreme
of the warrior like there's these
extremes that appear in roman art in the
desire to kind of
to lift up man and so
the orthodox christian said okay we can
take that no this is our this is our
this is the stuff we've got to work with
that's fine let's work with that and
then
keeping all the positive aspects of
roman art but then taming them you know
reorienting them having some
contrapposto but not the excessive one
we see you know both in roman and in the
renaissance post-renaissance time having
you know
emphasizing the this kind of beautiful
beautiful face for these kind of simple
beautiful faces all of this is something
that we ended up bringing back in you
know and so you can trace roman art
right up to the
up to the post uh iconoclasm uh work
like if you look at those carvings i
love those ivory carvings that come
after iconoclasm i mean all the tropes
of roman art are there but they've all
been reoriented the clothing has all the
same forms but all
all very the sensuousness is kind of
tamed in and so why couldn't we do that
again like you said with some of these
powerful
modern contemporary artists that have
been that have been
investigating some aspects of human
experience uh that's a very interesting
problem and it is
one that i think is unavoidable and
important one of the things we have to
remember is
i think we have to take this back
jonathan
the revival and i think we are heirs of
the revival of icon painting and the
sacred arts in the orthodox church okay
that's really important to understand
that yes the iconography
almost died like it didn't die but it
came very close people tend to think
that
orthodox iconography is just this thing
that blazed on for since the beginning
of of the church but that's not true
right in the in the the starting in the
18th century 19th century and then by
the early 20th century it's a trickle
like it's almost gone and so we have to
understand that we are the children of a
revival in the post-war period of of
iconography and we are we are the
the heirs of that for all good and ill
that it had within its seed you could
say right and that's uh that's the
important thing because i think in the
i think it it hasn't been until recently
that the
problematic dimensions of the revival
have
been considered
i know
as uh when i first became orthodox
it was
by default
that
the work of aspensky and kanteglu for
example it was it was considered by
default to be the authoritative
traditional perspective on
iconography yeah
and and and they have served a very
important catheterical role
in in bringing people to a cognizance of
the importance of traditional
iconography
but at the same time
um it has suffered from
oversimplification
the way people have taken their their
thought
and also
they themselves
i don't think
addressed or
were as honest no no that's not right to
say they were not as upfront
up front
about how important their modern context
was to
them being able to even frame the
questions that were different but do you
think maybe they were more they're
actually just unaware because they are
often not we are unaware of the frame in
which we say yes we exist and that frame
becomes apparent
you know as time goes on then we can
look back and say oh okay this is what
was going on and so i think that we
don't have to blame them in any way but
but also understand that they were doing
a monumental
insane work that we need to be you know
eternally grateful to them for yeah but
that in that desire to lift a mountain
they were bound to to to
to frame things you know a little often
to make some mistakes to to over
emphasize certain things like this is
what's bound to happen well you know
what uh to give credit to ospensky uh
the the the uh remember that article i
wrote about like his
i i mentioned where where
he in one of his uh
lessons mentions uh
um
matisse
yeah and and and and uh so he was he was
aware of how the icon played into
modernism
and and he did not
and and he he referred to matisse in a
positive way when he's teaching when he
was teaching his students so
so so you know
yeah you you also mentioned how close he
was to
and that whole
kind of neo-catholic art modern
neo-catholic art that was happening in
the early that was the context that was
totally the context and you know
what was that article the autonomy of
the icon yeah i think so where i i
basically tried to show the parallels
between
the symbolism of the 19th century that
was um
uh articulated by maurice denis
and how it pretty much
i mean it's
when you look at when you hear him speak
and then you hear uspensky speak or
contact you speak you're like oh right
so they're coming from the same attitude
towards the capacity of painting to
embody
something more than meets the eye
that is related to an inner experience
of nature but in the case of aspensky
encounter glue it's like given that the
orthodox they place that level of
cognition above
mere feelings they place it in the realm
of the noetic apprehension of things
okay so so anyway so
but i say that to say that there there
we have to look further into the
interesting convergence that existed
as you know as as the revival was
happening between
um the revivalists and modernism yeah
and so so if if we look at that honestly
then
we realize that we cannot escape
our own moment yeah and just like the
iconographers of the byzantine period
uh
felt like they were in continuity with
with the
the hellenic past yeah with the roman
are they felt completely like they were
continuing roman art right and so so
they did not see themselves as in any
way or form breaking away from it they
saw them as they tell themselves as
take like you describe taking aspects
revalorizing them for the purpose of
ecclesial function and so so similarly
what we need to do is take whatever it
is within our context
revalorize it and re-employ it for
the function that we have liturgically
as iconographers right so but the thing
is this and this is where
i think it's important to make a
distinction between
iconology
and stylistic form
because the iconology is
is a more complicated matter because
in a way you're dealing with
formulations
visual structures that convey specific
semiotic meanings if you want to call it
that way yeah might not be you know i
might not be using that being technical
about it yeah yeah okay so
but but what i'm talking about is
the formal aspects of the icon
that are in the realm of experiential
connection with the art object yeah so
color
coding line four exactly
so all these things either will
complement
augment
the iconology or it will actually work
against it yeah distract us from
distracting
so the key is to
there is in that sense a lot of freedom
within the formal dimension
uh because by default when i'm like
going to paint something i have to start
making decisions
i have to i can you know
it is it is a false understanding the
traditional iconography is
predicated solely on
uh mechanistic slavish copying of older
prototypes yeah
okay
well there are some people that do it
that way but it's a dead end exactly
it has it's definitely a dead end yeah
so so there is a value in it in you know
it it's a there's a value in it in the
in in the training process
but eventually what we want to do is
that actually
create works that come from a living
experience of the prototypes that we are
handling
the the the the final work has to be a
witness to our living encounter with
what it is that we're depicting
and if it is not
then we are not actually witnessing to
the continuing life of the holy spirit
in the church
and what we're doing is that we're
creating environments
that
counter
our
uh
call to spread the gospel
because people are gonna look into their
churches and they're gonna be like all
right so these people are like they're
stuck in the middle ages and they just
want to just basically perpetuate this
like romantic like
you know idea of themselves nostalgia
you're right
that's not like we want i always say
tradition without nostalgia exactly
that's my motto no because tradition is
it's it's
that one thing it also goes into
the fact that something is old doesn't
mean that it is
traditional exactly but also i want to i
want to bring something up just like
because i think we're right there is
that i i
what i've said until now is something
that i taught i i believe in all the
things that i've said but i think
there's also a caveat which is that
i also notice an another tendency in the
kind of the world of iconography which
is a desire for the experience of
novelty itself right the desire to be
titillated you could say by novelty and
i think that that
and so so i think that there are some
iconographers that want to use this
freedom that we talk about
uh to
let's say because what you're saying
make what we were saying until now makes
total sense if we are focused on the
basic idea we mentioned at the outset so
it's like i can integrate this or that
aspect of matisse if i'm my purpose is
to create objects with a specific
teleology that are there to to to exist
within the communion of the church that
are there to to to bring us you know to
not
call attention to themselves in a
disproportionate way all this stuff okay
um
but that
the flip side all is also true where
there's also people there's also some
iconography that i'm seeing around that
seems to to want to
almost idolize the novelty that as if
the idea of wanting to be in line with
the traditional forms is somehow useless
it's it's it's boring it's not
interesting and even that language of
saying like we want to make it
interesting we want to make art that is
that is contemporary in a in a very kind
of vague way so i think it's inevitable
we're going to make art that's
contemporary but it seems like we always
have to sub
subject that to the ultimate purpose and
the participation in the life of the
church and the liturgy uh and all of
that so i don't know if you have any
thoughts on that as well i think that is
always the
thing to keep in mind it is a crucial
uh
point to to to
not like
ignore because
i i agree i mean there are
and i encountered this myself because
it's the temptation is that you know i
don't want to do this because it's
boring because it's been done so many
times that like you know after a while
it's like how many times are you gonna
do it you know but the reality is it
serves a function and you have to do it
but but then at the same time it calls
you to be
more creative
if you're if you're sick and tired of
like you know look at but be creative in
a way that is a service to the community
not a self-indulgent
yeah i want to have some fun
so so you have to like you're saying
keep in mind the telos the function the
purpose of what it is that you're doing
is
ultimately as i like to say
for aiding people's
process their struggle towards
deification
and if if that is kept in mind and
you're using your discernment
and you are actually
harmonizing with
all the various voices
of the tradition
then you will produce something that is
authentic and something that is within
the spirit of the church that will have
a creative dimension to it but it's not
going to be like excessive
in its affirmation of
either yourself or or the our objects
for its own sake
and so that's
so but my my my contention my my fear is
on the other
side of the same coin that you're yeah
yeah yeah which is which is let's not i
think aidan has also pointed this out
let's not
be scared and then being scared like
bury our talent
in in this in this very you know uh
crucial like process of
of creative the discernment in the
creative process you know um
on top of what
we've been saying about
the viability of using things that have
come out of
a modern painting
i think it's also important to
[Music]
not
ignore the parallels that exist between
the iconographic tradition and other
forms of traditional art
for example
um persian manuscript illumination yeah
um the work of the
indian
miniaturist uh like the
uh rashford painting and you know bahari
painting and things like that and um
the tibetan
taga tradition for example the um
the chinese
and japanese painting traditions
and
when you really start looking at this
you realize
okay man
this is my hubris speaking right
uh
i look at some of our icons
and then i'm like
come on we have to we have to step up
we got we got to do something better man
and so i'm like you know
when i think like i i think that anybody
when we look at your icons i think this
is like my greatest compliment maybe not
my greatest one of my compliments of
your work which is that
when you look at an icon one of your
icons
for most people they get just this this
sense of wonder and beauty
and then for someone who knows he's like
like i know where he's pulling these
threads in from but they don't they
they're like a tapestry they don't they
don't uh they don't call attention to
themselves as threads like they don't
jar like you see i've seen some kind of
very kind of subversive type of uh of
icon painting you know where you it's
like it we're not subversive but like
but it just looks like a japanese prince
like it's just a japanese print with a
halo okay i mean yeah it's kind of
interesting i mean somewhat interesting
but i definitely wouldn't put that on
iconostasis but there's a way to dr to
pull in some of the patterns in japanese
print some of the composition some of
the line work for example that is that
is that is subtle enough to not call
attention to itself as a as a weird
string that's poking out of the tapestry
but integrates itself into in a way that
creates that sense of wonder i've
watched people like father shiloh like
i've never told you this but i've
watched people stand in front of your
your icons and i watch them
and and they just they like go into a
trance they're just like standing there
and they just look at it and you and you
and you're trying to like figure out
what's going on in their mind like
what's happening but i don't think they
even know like most people don't even
know what's going on but i think that
that i think touches on what we were
saying before about the uh
the uh
importance of form
having an effect
that is experiential that people will
not necessarily you cannot you cannot
codify it
or
quantify it
in a in a semiotic way yeah you
experience it it it it aids it aids
the function of it can aid if you can
yeah there you go that's great aid to
uh augment the function of the icon as a
support for contemplation
and that and and and what i like to say
is that
this contemplation embraces both feeling
and intellect
and when i say intellectual of course we
mean like no no i don't really know what
i'm saying right right so so so you have
you have the doctrinal message that
elevates you intelligibly but you are
also experiencing
a static
to the aesthetic form
also an elevation that puts you in the
frame of mind
that contributes towards stillness
towards a contemplative
uh entering into a participatory
connection with the work and so and so
this this i think
i partly have
i'm indebted i believe
from looking at at modern painting
because to me like okay for example like
ad reinhardt man
yeah
i mean some of rothko's painting some of
um
even even kenneth nolan paintings i mean
kenneth nolan it's like bordering on
getting a little bit too fabulous yeah
you know what i'm saying but in his best
moments
you're encountering a a color experience
that you're like how did this guy come
up with this vision
and and and it puts you in like you're
saying a zone you know right so but this
zone has to be actually
brought
it has to be something that brings you
towards the ultimate like it's a vehicle
for higher things not for the zone is
not enough yes it has exact service of
god exactly no no totally totally but
that's the that's the key
um but that is very important because
otherwise i think my
my my uh
concern
is that
unfortunately
there is perhaps i'm exaggerating maybe
not you tell me how you feel about this
there is a tendency of using iconography
for philotic purposes
what i mean by that is
given that
orthodoxy has experienced
trauma after trauma historically
collapse of constantinople turkish right
the the communist revolution you know
what i'm saying all these various
instances that have
contributed to
it's like like you know yeah i think
yeah constantly beaten on um the
tendency is then for people and also
other other issues of like during the
turkish europe for example
like the the the patriarch became a an
ethnic leader right yeah so so so the
the the the the
uh ottoman authorities used them
as a legislator of these specific ethnic
groups yeah so then then orthodoxy
became closely linked to your ethnic
identity
and and also the whole issue of
patriarchy throughout the history of
orthodoxy have inculcated a sense of
like a ethnic identity and the almost
like undiscernable or undifferentiatable
like you know connection between
ethnicity and orthodoxy right but that's
problematic yeah and it seems to me that
in the realm of iconography what happens
is that
local churches
tend to
uh
fixate on specific forms visually that
they
deem to be appropriate in embodying
their sense of ethnic identity yeah
and
my advantage
is
i'm not greek you're not part of it i'm
not russian i'm not
puerto rico never had a patriarchy right
or america you know right you have the
oca but then there's that's the work in
progress right yeah like the idiocephaly
and things like that
so so
we are in an environment or i am in an
environment as you as well like we live
in a world that is more
uh
it's not less of that of that
temptation you could say exactly
so we have we have access
to all this wealth of visual
reference material
that we could use
as a means
to strengthen like uplift like
make iconography
more
flourishing and and instead of thinking
that if
i don't do it this way then i'm
betraying my nation where i'm between
you know the church because i have such
a close
like i make such an uh close connection
between ethnicity and and religion you
know so so i think
i think it's important to emphasize that
iconography is not greek iconography
it's not russian iconography you know
one of the problems that aspensky and
kanteglu had
when they were having their conversation
the letters they wrote to each other was
all right what are we going to consider
to be the classical form the best to
follow
and of course
kanta glu thought it was cretan you know
folk like you know
16th century yeah uh greek works and
while
you know uh
it was the you know the 15th or 16th
century you know what i'm saying russian
right and russian stuff and so and they
didn't they didn't agree but the thing
is
iconography
is not set in stone
we follow a tradition
and the tradition is there to keep
us focused on primary
concerns
meanings that we are trying to embody
through the iconographic tradition that
that kind of graphic form in music
similarly you know and so
architecturally similarly right so we
have this
this this variety of of of things that
uh forms aesthetic
uh tendencies that we have received that
we have to work with that we don't cast
out because they work
and they already serve as a context
where people
come in and they already know where
they're what they're inhabiting yeah and
so we are to take this
and elevate it more and more and more
and more by our putting our contribution
not out of like some like selfish kind
of like you know self-aggrandizing
purpose but as a service to the
community
and so that means that your talent
my talent
aiden hearts talent you know cordis
talent torador's talent whoever it is
around
we have been given
a very unique capacity
and we use it for the service of the
church we have to use it for the service
of the church but to try to somehow
uh
stomp it because
we interpret it as being
self-assertion
or or or buying into the self-expressive
theory of modern art
i don't think it's that simple i think i
think there is a a
a uh
uh
room
for the uniqueness of the person
and this is one
pivotal critique
that i don't think
has been addressed
uh has been made before with the work of
kumaswami
because komaswami was excessively
platonic
yeah and and his notion of tradition
was predicated on the
hindu vedanta philosophical tradition
which completely denied the importance
of the hypothesis yeah the person
there's no sense of the person in uh and
so for him when he sees us at uh the
tendency in traditional art towards
anonymity
he interprets it
from a vedantist point of view yeah an
excessively platonic view where like we
will shed our bodies and we will shed
our personalities and we will identify
ourselves with the one
and or the atman the self with a capital
s and so all the
illusions that the suffering cost
because of us constructing this false
notion of self that would be done away
with and we have bliss no
we like saying makari is the great i
think it is and his muhammad ali's it's
you know say saint paul remain saint
paul say peter remains saint peter all
the saints remain who they are but they
are
they're they reach their true identity
in christ without completely
losing their their person yeah and so
and so that's an important distinction
to make and i think
the contemporary
place in which we find ourselves today
as iconographers is one in which we have
to make that that distinction and
clarify that in emphasizing the personal
dimension of iconography is not buying
into
self uh angridizing self expression in
the individualistic sense if anything is
a way of rebuttaling tendencies that
could be excessively
platonic yeah or excessively hindu that
have come
through
the
amazing
help without him even realizing of
people like kumar swami yeah and and i
think that it's like it's similar to the
when we talked about in terms of
national imagery that you just have to
find a balance there's a balance it's
like we love russian iconography we love
greek iconography we love serbian
iconography georgian it's beautiful it
has
its wonderful particularities that we
celebrate and maybe the same also in the
sense of great iconographers who have
some particularity that we celebrate we
just have to find the balance between
understanding how that
coexists with this move towards unity
and it really is the christian story in
the end it really is it is this balance
of unity and multiplicity which we find
already in the trinitarian theology and
ultimately in the way the church exists
it's the is the story of pentecost
it's it's is because you know uh it's a
continuum in pentecost i think that's
that aidenhart has put it before one of
his articles where like each nation has
something to contribute
each nation
is is united
in christ
they don't lose their identity
but the catholicity of the church
presupposes that it is the healing of
the confusion that happened in the tower
of babel
and so they they we all come together
and even if the you know each person has
a flame on top of their head right each
each apostle right so it's like
individual tongues of fire but they they
still is still the same holy spirit this
diversity of gifts but the same spirit
so so similarly with different
uh
temperaments
different uh capacities artistically
these are
prophetic is you know the the the
prophet prophesies like saint paul says
but this their spirit is not taken away
from them they still have they're
cooperating with divine grace
and so we are to cooperate with divine
grace and that means that
whatever is healthy good
will uh flourish and what is not good
that we could put aside we will for the
service of the church but uh the
individual and the
uh the temperamental uniqueness that
each person or nation offers is for the
world like the the um
the wealth of the church
um and so that's that's that's that it
makes a manifest and witnesses to the
catholicity of the church in the holy
spirit
i think that's that was a that was an
amazing way to to end our our discussion
with that last
that last uh encouragement and so father
sylvan thank you so much as you know i
love i i love your work so much and i
think that thank you you know for people
who don't know i i have one drawing from
father silawan we did an exchange
several years ago of a drawing which is
one of my favorite things in the world
it's in my living room now but uh but
i'm also very fortunate to be able to
receive hopefully soon an icon from
father siluwan and so i'm really excited
to i'll show everybody when when i
receive it so uh so i i would say go to
his website i will put a link in the
description to the work he's doing to
his articles uh he is a he is a shining
light in the world of uh of american
iconography but honestly also i think in
the iconography in in the world uh
period and so father siloan thank you
for your time and thank you for giving
me the opportunity
it's been uh
we tried to do this a while back but i'm
glad we finally got it and it's been
actually
you know providentially
actually worth the wait because uh it
was a good conversation and thank you
for giving me the opportunity
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support